[Musique]
il ne respire pas
il n'est pas pourquoi on est unis parmi
les vivants ni parmi les morts son âme
est éternel vous avez la possibilité de
le sauver
le prix à payer est assez élevé je vous
ai manqué un massacre a lieu
tous ces meurtres ne peuvent pas être
relié la vengeance et soulagera travaux
très triste
si vous n'êtes pas le tueur alors vous
êtes ont compris
nous sommes intéressés par le secret de
la vie éternelle
les hommes d'honneur sont rares ils ont
tendance à disparaître
[Musique]
j'attendais ce jeu les puissiez rire
je vous ai rencontré et avec vous j'ai
découvert il moore
pas la tuer
tu vas vivre
enfant des ténèbres
l'essor
[Musique]
ils ont messi tevez et higuain victoire
comme la seule occasion corps au bord du
lac
il
mais
[Musique]
thq d'alcool et plus encore
je
m
grâce à des buts
[Musique]
des décrets
et faire que la présente en mai
apache on croit en toi on a décidé de
proposer un contrat
j'm'en fous ta cg c'est le mode push
mais le feu sur la ba a pris attache moi
c'est gris qui vient de faire la france
n'importe quoi ce cycle un but en contre
mais je sais que je vais passer mes
romans de loin bouzou
il faut partager frère et par thor qui
rappe le quartier s'y adapter je veux ma
part
continuez de faire tes showcase dans des
chichas était pas faire ça chez vous si
tu veux mes albums et tu fais un choix
plutôt c'est moi on sait lui une note
adressée au maire connaît
on peut plus vivre sur terre dit au
revoir à notre planète
bienvenue à bord dan yara le vaisseau de
transport spatial le plus moderne qui
soit qui vous emmènera de la terre
jusqu'à mars en trois semaines
[Musique]
nous avons détecté une anomalie moteur
3 2
le vaisseau a dévié de sa trajectoire
nous risquons d'errer dans l'espace pour
toujours
nous sommes les premiers hommes à aller
aussi loin dans la galaxie
[Musique]
on est tous condamnés
non
[Musique]
bref
j
[Musique]
ce
oh
messieurs
[Musique]
papa tu es quelqu'un d'obstiné de bornes
et de magnac un rouspéteur psychorigide
c'est gentil ça doit être mon
anniversaire
je sais qu'on n'arrive pas soir autant
qu'on aimerait pouvoir le faire mais
quand on y arrive je dois reconnaître
que c'est fabuleux à l'amitié à la
bienvenue à bord monsieur
c'est magnifique chez toi quel dommage
cette [ __ ] de fulminer un tout petit
bémol au paradis
notre arrangement j'y repensais le thé
quoi à temps et écoute moi on a réglé sa
ya 20 ans on à faire patte les roues je
suis plus du tout le même homme mais
marc deviens qui tu es et m on m'a
contacté pour jouer une grand-mère au
nom 60 ans aujourd'hui ses 40 ans hier
ouais bien sûr vu de dos et dans l'oise
non mais regardez au compositeur de
jingle raté une actrice vieillissante le
monde dans lequel on vit
c'est plus pour nous pourquoi billy est
un connard aussi ingrat pts
écoute moi petit sûr pas faire [ __ ]
tout connu au monde qu'est ce que tu
fabriques food et non c'est faux quoi
vous êtes nous sommes là pour célébrer
ta rationnelle et irrigue la curité le
bon vieux sage que tu es devenu tu dois
me parler enfin
j'aurais jamais dû vendre l'entreprise
le jour où je les vends du je me suis
sentie mourir pour moi tas d'autres
choses
on ne voulait pas avoir d'enfant quand
je regardais tiens tiens de subir mes
enfants mon vieux
toutes ces années il a été marié à son
boulot à tétouan sas étrangers c'était
beaucoup plus qu'une simple aventure
lotis
[Musique]
j'ai bousillé toutes les bonnes choses
et tu es la meilleure d'entre elles
tu sais parfois tu dois juste profiter
de tout ce qui t'entoure
et pour tout une place
promets moi que les dix années qui
viennent seront les meilleurs taux notre
fille mais là c'est tellement de chance
toi billy thème toujours façon dont ils
regardent
non il est trop vaniteux pour mettre ses
lunettes il vit dans un grand bruit
[Rires]
[Musique]
e
le bac téléscripteur bien d'accord
biechlin sofica
[Musique]
s'enregistrer en augmentant cloud
voorhees sigurdsson de ligue 1 face au
talent du jeune michel
alphan manas sid
[Musique]
les pratiques rosario passe
je passe
[Musique]
jobs mardi
exploit